i had to take some time today to to
bring on a dear friend of mine
um who was quoted as saying the
milwaukee bucks are the worst nba finals
team
of all time at some point during the
series amino hassan joins the show
i forget the words exactly but what were
your thoughts on milwaukee earlier in
the series i mean
yeah most people forgot the words and
the context and that's all that runs is
that little clip but you know what i
said it's all stand by it no uh
you know this is after game two uh
giannis
was i had a remarkable game too but
didn't look like himself obviously nor
should we have expected him to
coming off of a that knee injury where
his
knee looked like an elbow where it
looked like a flamingo's knee like
barely about
nine or ten days earlier and everyone
else was on a milk carton
and they were you know uh it wasn't like
this is the first time we see the bucks
look discombobulated and at the time i
said look the suns are
well coached they're well well their
stars are playing great and their role
players
not only are playing great within their
roles within themselves
but they were playing uh great in and of
that you know like consistently well
throughout the playoffs on the whole
on the road at home didn't matter so at
the time
i just didn't have a whole lot of
confidence in milwaukee making
the adjustments needed to turn the
series around
especially with giannis being hobbled on
one leg
and then he got better and they got
better
and you know things happened the way
they did i mean i joke with you uh
because i was right there with you i
tweeted out after game two the suns are
better at every aspect of basketball and
they have a guy named devin booker so
it's a wrap next series please uh so
yeah i get it man with new information
comes new opinions and giannis seemed to
pick up the last infinity stone and turn
into thanos i don't know what happened
you're a marvel guy which avenger did he
turn into last night was he tony stark
figuring out the suit or was he bruce
banner controlling his rage
no he was he was thor when he went and
got the new hammer
it he looked broken at one point
like thor and then he went and got like
a new hammer and was like oh
it turns out like uh it's not really the
hammer that holds the powers i'm the one
that holds the power
the hammer is just a tool for me to
focus it
and sure enough in that context ben
early in these playoffs before that
injury
giannis was playing on the perimeter a
lot they give the ball to him 23 feet
out
and he'd have to dribble and create and
teams were building walls and
regardless whether he had big games or
not it was a hard way for milwaukee to
score but
and the knee injury one of the weird
kind of
work of the tragedy
giving you some sort of new way to look
at things
giannis's kind of lack of mobility that
he had early in the series
forced milwaukee to play him the way i
thought they should have played him all
along
like a center like a big just get near
the basket
catches nearer to the paint let them
operate like that
and that combined with the dario showers
injuries
forced phoenix to go small every time
they went to the bench
made giannis focus on the thing that
he's actually great at and that in turn
gave us
the giannis explosion that we saw uh
throughout these finals
amino hassan joins the show meadowlark
media cinephobe podcast we'll talk some
movies in a little bit with the mean as
well
former phoenix suns front office
executive
and last night we saw not only giannis
coming to his full powers as the greek
god from a far-off land like
thor in asgard we saw chris middleton do
his 24
hour fitness thing you see you see uh
chris middleton at the gym play five
games in a row that's what it was like
last night when he got the ball with one
minute left
talk to me just a little bit about chris
middleton his story
his place in nba finals history after
this series
yeah so i remember going to go see chris
at texas a m
uh in 2012 when i was a scout for the
phoenix suns
um and he didn't play that game and so
i've always told chris i held that
grudge against them because they made me
go all the way down to
the college station which i don't know
if you've been there ben
not exactly scenic territory i haven't
had the pleasure i haven't had the
pleasure i'm not on the john buddish
world tour i mean like you are yeah
our mutual friend john budden loves
places like that that should tell you
exactly
the type of town college station is uh
but you know
second round pick for detroit it was
okay
wasn't anything to write home about was
like a decent nba player
gets traded in the brandon jennings deal
and gets to milwaukee and him and
giannis are
are their first year milwaukee together
and
neither of them are especially good but
their flashes there and
do a lot of work and skill uh training
you see chris middleton abe would come
into a really remarkable shooter but be
a really good defensive player and i
think that's the part that gets lost
sometimes when we talk about chris
middleton
we talk about 50 40 90 his shooting
percentages a lot
but we don't talk enough about what a
good defensive player he is
and him and jan is kind of the iron
sharpening iron
in practices going from guys on the
bench to guys who are starting and then
the two stars of the team to all stars
it really
is quite the journey and quite the the
uh
the path uh and it makes the bucks kind
of a real feel-good story in that regard
i mean do you think somewhere in
positano last night james harden had a
bowl of bolognese and was sitting there
watching the game thinking man
i gotta get back in the lab and and do
something too
to come out here and get this guy off
the mountain do you think there's a
universe where
kyrie irving logged off the zoom with
cynthia nixon and said man i need to
i need to get back in the lab how does
giannis's win
permeate throughout the nba yeah james
harden is thinking
man pony hour 17 could just dunk on
everybody because apparently that's all
the honest does according to james
harden
uh and that's for for for kyrie god
knows what he's up to right now but
i'm sure it's fulfilling it's a journey
of discovery and
and enlightenment no i think you know
the
the a lot of people are asking what does
this mean now i think it means that it's
always meant
if you draft a star player you have
seven to eight years
to prove to him we know what we're doing
we're heading in the right direction
we're going to get there right we and we
are committed to getting there
we're not worried about the bottom line
we're not worried about
uh you know things that are five six
years down the line
we're trying to be the best team that we
can be right now
right um if you do not do that
at the end of seven or eight years guess
what those guys are gonna leave
they're gonna demand to get traded or
they're gonna leave in free agency
depending on how their second contracts
are structured so
i don't think anything has changed here
milwaukee for the last three years has
been one of the best teams in the league
one of the highest winning percentages
and giannis has been a two-time mvp and
a defensive player of the year in that
span
and uh they've had playoff success
not as much as they thought they'd have
but playoff success nonetheless
so in terms of what this means
i think it means the same thing it's
always meant if you run your
organization the right way
you can have a star player stay you can
have role players come take less like
bobby porter did
you can you can have you can acquire
talent wherever you can find it like a
chris middleton buy a dr
by trade like a pt tucker by a
mid-season trade
but if you mismanage your team you can't
be mad when your stars say you know what
i'm taking my talents elsewhere
amino hassan joins the show one half of
the cinephobe podcast you can catch them
across meadowlark media now as well
i'm glad you mentioned bobby portis once
a nick always a nick we woke up in a
world today
i mean where bobby portis is an nba
champion
i just looked at life differently the
breakfast tasted a little better this
morning
talk about his performance though 16
points last night it was big for the
bucks they needed him last night
oh no he was the second best player i
know middleton ended up scoring more
but bobby portis was consistently making
shot the only guy making shots for the
bucks
when it felt like giannis was going to
have to win this thing on his own
50 points out of 104 that's not that's
not great
so uh you know but portis absolutely was
massive and it wasn't just last game he
did it in game five he did in game four
and then active on the board good
defensively
on those switches um the right amount of
energy intensity although they're almost
almost kind of spilled over there when
he got that technical foul and
chris middleton had to remind them hey
man it don't matter whether you fall
them or not
you can't go on and get a technical foul
on top of it so
you know for bobby porter again these
are the stories that i really
really gravitate to the bobby portis is
even on the losing side of cameron payne
guys that were kind of their nba careers
were kind of in question
and they they got an opportunity with a
good team
showed how they can contribute to
winning and hopefully this summer both
of those guys are going to go get
themselves some money
incredible moment after the game i mean
when monty williams was in the phoenix
sun's locker room
there was a man to his left just
pounding a giant magnum bottle of rose i
thought you might know who that is
but i did want to ask you more about the
monty williams
uh moment and just what he means to
phoenix to the nba
and just your thoughts on monty after
you see him after the game
let me let me just start by saying monty
williams is an
excellent human being right he is you
know how they call him the best among us
he is literally one of the best among us
just
a genuine good guy who's well liked
everybody teach everybody respect for me
and uh he treats his job respectfully
very good coach i thought he did an
awesome job with this team
not just this year but last year i
thought he didn't often job in these
finals
i mean it's hard to stop something like
jonathan so i i
i wish nothing but the best for vermont
having said that
i felt it was a little too look at me
louie out there
i mean you're gonna walk into the
winner's
locker room in the middle of their
championship celebration make them pause
the celebration
and say a big speech about how you've
made me a better coach and how you've
made us a better team
come on if you're that empathetic where
you know
hey even in this moment of defeat i
gain a kernel of of victory by having
faced this formidable foe
then you're empathetic enough to know
i'll just wait until they i catch him in
the hallway well part of this story is
giannis ushered him in apparently the
story goes that giannis encouraged him
to come in and ask him to come in he
came to the locker room
yeah yeah i heard him from the visitors
locker room he saw him in the doorway
hey come in man like this there's a big
difference there between like
hey just walking by or whatever and you
making the trek there
i i don't like again if it were anywhere
else but monty i feel like there are a
lot of people
would be on my side on this one i get it
i'm not popular anyway so i'm okay with
taking
the unpopular stances which is i was a
little bit man
let them have their moment no i get it i
mean i get it i mean i get it
i get it i mean the milwaukee bucks are
the worst nba finals team and monty
williams is a look at me i totally get
it i mean i totally get it oh one of
those things is true
uh i want to talk about the cinephone
podcast you do a great job with zach
harper set the premise
for our listeners about what makes your
film podcast a little bit different
oh well every year movies come out and
they're
some of them are very highly rated
certified fresh by rotten tomatoes and
some of them are poorly rated
and we kind of just look at the poorly
rated ones i'm not going to watch that
and leave it alone
but zach harper and i we took it upon
ourselves to watch movies that are
poorly rated on rotten tomatoes
and try to ascertain whether they are in
fact accurately poorly rated
or maybe been just maybe they didn't get
a fair
shake that's cynical produced by anthony
mays
wherever you get podcasts and by the way
ben lyons has been a guest on cinephone
so that's all the
field of approval i need yeah then 275
gets you on the subway now in new york
city i appreciate you having me on the
show
a movie i'd love to have on that show is
black rain you ever seen that with
michael douglas and a young andy garcia
michael douglas a dirty cop goes across
the world to japan to just go to
investigate a murder
and it's fifty percent on rotten
tomatoes that's pretty lousy
blackberry lousy but not quite lousy
enough our
minimums are our score that you need to
hit is 40
or lower by either the critics or the
audience by the way
ben this month we're doing john travolta
month we've been doing
months every every month of the year
this month has been john travolta month
we did killing season with travolta and
robert de niro
we did uh staying alive with travolta
and directed by sylvester stallone and
this week actually today the new episode
that dropped we did look who's talking
to
travolta kirstie alley bruce willis
roseanne barr and a hell of a song
by uh uh a former beatle
whose name escapes me not ringo not paul
not
not john the other one george harrison
george harrison i mean
el hassan yeah george uh is that look
who's talking now or is that look who's
talking to are there three look who's
talking movies
there's three look who's talking look
who's talking look who's talking to
look who's talking now look talking too
is the addition
of the baby sister who's played by
roseanne barr look who's talking now is
the one with the pets
that one was really bad but this one
looks good talking too is the one that
we did
and so i won't say how i reviewed it
because i want you guys all to go and
looking of course
you've uh you've had a interesting takes
on film since i've known you i know
you're a big star wars fan i know you
dress up on opening night when they play
the movies at the grove
that's fine that's totally cool i
celebrate that you know you know i dress
up in an anthony bonner jersey every
once in a while like i get it um
but but this would i would imagine doing
this podcast has sort of changed the way
you look at film and especially to
change the way you look at
bad movies that you go and revisit well
first of all whoever was snickering in
the background that wasn't a joke
there's a picture of him floating around
with an anthony bonner jersey at a
bar mitzvah is that right
again john voodoo's getting another
shout out on the segment the day he
became a man i thought i'd honor him in
the tradition of
judaism by wearing an anthony bonner
jersey wow
but yeah as far as how it changed my
outlook on movies uh
ben i'm gonna tell you this there's a a
a
a term in filmmaking i call exposition
exposition is when
characters start to just explain things
rather than go ahead and do it
for in the interest of saving time right
to move the story along
just say hey just got back from the army
like why would you announce that well
that's exposition they just want to let
you know this person got back from the
army
and they don't want to show you them in
the army and all that stuff
and now that i've done this movie and
seen so many bad movies that
do heavy-handed exposition my exposition
meter is extremely sensitive i can watch
great movies
and in the middle of a great kind of
little piece of dialogue i just point
out
exposition that i can't shake it i can't
look away
i i can't ignore my suspension of
disbelief has been
ruined by this podcast ben lyons in for
rich on the rich eisen show joined by
amin elhassen one host uh one half of
the
cinephi uh cinephone podcast he hosts
alongside
zach harper you got so many titles and
middle uh metal arc media and this and
that it's a little bit of a mouthful
right now too many slashes
there's a little bit of attention i
don't know if you've heard about this
between cinephobe
my podcast is zach harper that's
produced by anthony mays
and cinephile the admin work podcast
that he that is produced by chris cody
of meadowlark metallocmedia
they started it they started this war of
words and so here we are
and you know what i think cinephile is
too
stuck up it's too stuffy it's too boring
and ant-man is a ball hog
whoa yeah i said it that man xenophobe
that's where you want to go folks
that's one for the people as someone
who's been a guest on both podcasts let
me just say cinephile has come
first only one of those podcast hosts
called an academy awards has an iconic
call
moonlight just won best picture
moonlight one best picture
adnan with a legendary call in hollywood
i got a lean cinephile they've been
there
they've done it they've done it at a
high level and they're not spending time
talking about roseanne barr movies
so it sounds like a win over there you
know what you sound like you sound like
chris paul the greatest point guard ever
and devin booker is a great offensive
player and they play so beautifully so
they're going to be champions but you
know what we are over here at cinephobe
blue collar hard working up by our
bootstraps
no lottery picks on our roster that's
right we're second rounders
and guys that were like passed over 14
times in the first round
and guys who were like on the top end
block we're the milwaukee bucks
cinephobe if you support the champs
you'll support cinephobe
i mean where do you think eric bledsoe
watched the game last night
oh my god that's one of those ones
that's like you can't win either way
right
i tried to think of who were the saddest
people watching that game last night
eric bledsoe was number one on the list
bogdan bogdanovic
has to be pretty high on that list too
right he's sitting there thinking if it
wasn't for some
mealy-mouthed little reporter put my
business out in the streets a few days
too early
i'd be sipping champagne too i also
think the guy counting the money in
phoenix last night it's got to be a
tough day for him
i think uh sons and four guy is starting
to
that those 15 minutes are starting to
tick it's like the justin timberlake
amanda seifried movie
out of time which would be a great
contender on cinephobe to go back and
look because i don't think
out of time with justin timberlake gets
its proper respect i agree with you
great i think that's great i've been
saying her name
wrong this whole time i thought it's
amanda seafree
sci saiford seafreed amanda seyfried
i don't know she's the girl from mamma
mia right yeah she's nominated for
i don't know amanda seifried i think is
hey i mean real quick
what are we talking about today if kevin
durant wears the right size shoe
yeah that's one of the great what-ifs
right because everyone is
praising the bucks for the jewel holiday
deal everyone who thinks he was all
worth it to give up all those pics
and hey he played great these finals
defensively he made his impact and he
was absolutely an essential part of this
championship
but if kevin durant wears a smaller
sized shoe as you
positive we're probably talking about
the brooklyn nets
today being in the championship and drew
how they do the first two rounds of the
playoffs was
forgettable at best and we start to look
at that deal
a lot differently and that's what makes
the nba so fascinating right
it's some things that can be like you
idiot and then it turns out to be
the thing that takes you over the top
like oh you genius
but you know if one little thing goes
wrong here or there
it could be going back to you idiot all
over again
uh well it's a great question and you
know you can also say hey would they
have gotten past
the hawks because you know harden
and and kyrie still probably wouldn't
have been healthy uh
would they have gotten past his sons if
they got past the hogs no one knows
who'd be the champion today
but i do know would be looking at
milwaukee a lot different and by the way
not just drew holiday in that deal
but we'd be looking at my business are a
lot different right
once a nick executive always nick
executive amino hassan joins the show
from meadowlark media
the sliding doors of the nba is what we
celebrate you're absolutely right
appreciate you spending some time be
sure to download subscribe rate and
review the cinefo
podcast wherever podcasts are uh
downloaded and available
thanks buddy thanks ben amino hassan
joins the show love that guy
interesting guy hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here